γώ νομίζω ή αποφάεις του κόμματος η τελευταίς ήταν καθοριστικές για το ότ γίνεται σε
τεθκεες περιπτώσεις νομίζω είναιτοτού τον που λέγει αβλο στατικόδιαγραφή και ταν και φόσο για να
μην υπάρχει διαύρωση του μηνύματος οφίλο να πω ότι εγώ διαφωνησαν με την απόφαση νεψη
σαιαφορετικά θεωρώ τοαλλά ία σω και μεγαλι σημασίάν ενανάτομο ένποπιστεριδη ότι ε συνέδρια και σε
άπαψει σηκολομόντως έρι μας αναλόγω με το ότιναιριτο υπριαυπάρξει διαγραφιρίτω των τελέγχο που τι στημπή
που δεν υπήρξε στηναρχή με θεώρεσα ότι ήταν ήτανν ακαιρό όμως σε κάθε περίπτωσή α
ππιο πολύ πλογόνασμεν πούμε πιο πολύ πλο ότι αντίληψημο για το ότι είναι ο δημοκρατηκός
συναγερμό ξι όπως τι σημαίνει μητρόν κόμματο σας του δημοκραικού συαγερμό αλλολόμπουκινο που σημαίνει σ
ένα κ συγκεντρωτικό πολλά διαφορετικό πράγμα διαφορετικά αντίληψημος προς το πρτη βλέπω ότι ενα ένα
κομμάνω πρέλλα της δεξιάς και το οποιό μαςφαίνεο μησμιας συζήση ότι αυτό ενώαυτόν είναι και
αυτό πρέπει να είναι ο δημοκρατιώς συναγρμόν μακριά που τα πρόσωπα και θέλω να πω
τούτον θέλω να ερμηνυτί ότύυπος τρίζω χρις το δουλίδινή αν ήταν ή αβέρωόφ αναστασιάδι είναι
οποιο δήποτε που τού τον πουλέω μια γεννικό τερί φιλοσοφία δικήμου ότι το δημοκρατιώς ε
αγερμός πρέπει να είναι ανοικτόν απκομπάνο πρέλλα μέα σας ετού τον τοστιχί το οποιον καλύπτι
όλι τη δεξιά και ανέ δυναδόν τη μεγάλη βλεξη άν που πολύ συζητούσαμε νι μεγαλώσαμε
μαζίτης που υτάνει το κέντρον στο κέντρον όπως το εκαθορισμένο στην κύπρο το κέντρό σε
όλες τις δημοκρατικές